[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the st.
Louis rapid and blitz the fourth event
of the year for the grand chess or it is
the inaugural event who's seeing it here
for the very first time here in st.
Louis and there's a special buzz around
this event for a very good reason as
it's the return of the King Gary
Kasparov once again in competition after
retiring since 2005 12 years since he's
played against his professional
colleagues in an official competition
and he is back in this event and there
is a tremendous buzz with the audience
hi Maurice Ashley Maurice Ashley and it
for me is a special treat I've been
following Garry Kasparov's career for
many many years and been able to comment
on all his epic battles of many of his
epic battles so it's absolutely
thrilling for me to see a personal hero
once again playing and you one is of
course reminded of the return of
Muhammad Ali of Michael Jordan one of
the all-time greats in the history of a
sport and certainly a special event that
we're gonna be witnessing over the next
five days well before we get to those
duties I will first like to introduce
the players who will have a say in how
well won Garry Kasparov does in this
event and we have a few new faces we
also have several faces who are friends
virtually family now let me introduce
new to the competition a wild card here
grandmaster lee lam from vietnam
[Applause]
also new to the competition all the way
from the Czech Republic brat master
David Navarro a veteran of these events
a veteran of st. Louis and definitely a
friend to the city a winner of the
Sinquefield Cup the third edition of the
Sinquefield Cup from Armenia grandmaster
Levon Aronian a man who knows a thing or
two about playing against Garry Kasparov
he competed against him in a world
championship match and has played
against him I think more than probably
any of these players combined against
Garry Kasparov certainly a champion
himself five-time world champion in fact
from India grandmaster Vishwanath on an
on top player himself and we welcome him
welcoming him for the first time to st.
Louis from Cuba Grandmaster Alania
Dominguez go to the other end of the
podium one of America's brightest star
is a four-time US Champion it's been a
top player for many years now
Grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura hailing from
Russia grandmaster Yana Pagliacci
and his compatriots
a challenger to the world title recently
Grandmaster Sergei car yak in another
American superstar a winner of the
Sinquefield Cup will never forget his 7o
run to begin the competition of feat
that will take many years if not decades
to once again repeat Grandmaster Fabiano
Caruana and of course if I try to list
all his accomplishments we'd be here for
a couple of hours at least and that's
only the first half of his career he is
a champion of champions he has won the
World title many times ever since he
defeated Anatoly Karpov in their epic
match in 1985 he was a number one player
in the world for 15 years he's an
ambassador he's someone who was a
visionary off the grand chest tour as
well he continues to do much work all
over the world his foundations
throughout the world help kids and help
spread the word about our royal game he
has done everything this sport is that
to offer and he plans with a little bit
more to regale us at this event I'm sure
he's been hard in training but please
welcome everyone grandmaster garry
kasparov
[Applause]
and to say a few words will introduce
the executive director off the st. Louis
chess club is classic senator tony rich
Thank You Maurice I have to say just
coming off the sink filled cup it was so
much fun watching the players that were
in town I really feel like these events
are kind of st. Louis's crowning jewel
when it comes to chess and the rapid and
blitz this new event I absolutely will
do more to astound all of the spectators
and fans and the dorks that love chess
like me so I can't wait to see what
happens over the next five days
obviously there are many many people to
thank there have been a lot of folks who
have been very integral and important
and making sure these events come off as
successfully as they have I'd like to
start with spectrum studios run by Randy
Sinquefield
and silverback as well Tom Wilkinson of
course I would be remiss if I didn't
mention our PR team fleischman-hillard
as long with mark tabling and Kylie
Herndon who make all of the events that
we have here be as popular as they are
of course I would like to thank all of
our commentators I think we're gonna
mention them by name in just a little
bit so I won't ruin maurices thunder but
of course we have Spanish commentators
in st. Louis we have live audience
commentators we have commentators who
are broadcasting on the Internet
we even have grandmasters who are in
town that help us with simple things
like bringing a little insight or
sideline reporting from the events as
well Christian journalist so thanks to
all of our commentators are here and of
course none of this would be possible
without the Chess Club and scholastic
Center of st. Louis and the world chess
Hall of Fame led by Shannon Bailey you
know it's it's been so much fun to be
able to work at the organization now and
it's great to have my partner in arms
with Shannon of course all of the the
the Grantchester stops have sponsors and
organizers that are very important to
the event in Paris we have Vivendi
dailymotion and Colliers International
and the Paris leg I'm sorry we have
Colliers International in the Louvin leg
we have your next move we just finished
up our third leg in the sink filled cup
this is number four with the st. Louis
rapid and blitz and we wrap things up in
London
with the London chess classic that's led
by the very the great organizer Malcolm
Payne and chess promotions limited you
know I've worked at the Chess Club now
for almost ten years would be ten years
in January and it has been the most
amazing job anybody could ask for you
know these guys have been my idols I've
looked up to them I've tried to mimic
their games of chess poorly but I've
tried for a number of years now but none
of that would have been possible of
course without my boss Rex Sinquefield
and his vision but more importantly his
boss dr. Jeanne Singh field Jeanne well
I always get the joy to introduce Rex I
want to thank everybody for coming we
have seven countries being represented
right now with a few new people who have
never played here we're so welcome to
the city of st. Louis the chef's capital
of the US and I wanted to give you a
little bit of helpful advice
don't play the Sinquefield move and I
would like to introduce the godfather of
at least st. Louis chess it's not us
chess Rex Sinquefield
oh my goodness what a note he looks like
that umpire in the 1985 World Series
that made that bad call in the sixth
game of the World Series against the
Cardinals and the Royals Dan denken sure
and the hardest thing to take was he
lived in st. Louis but to his credit he
went on camlocks radial the next day for
two hours and took all questions I
didn't do that
yeah sure Sara Juan describes that event
when I incorrectly promoted upon to a
queen and cost the game for which I got
daggers from this fella to my right
Yaser says it's like Bob Hope being
thrown out of his own tournament so
anyway I want to just spend time
thanking the staff my son Randy and his
crew and incredible the most incredible
announcement I say it all the time I
know it gets boring but I'm not gonna
stop saying it the most incredible
commentary team of any sport in the
world and I dare anyone to challenge me
on that jennifer Shahadah yester Sara
Juan and Maurice Ashley
[Applause]
and then alongside them in other
quarters doing live commentary we have
also the best in the world vara Kobe and
Robert s a king cider diner in Alejandro
and Evette doing Spanish commentary that
muchas specialism us yeah yeah yeah all
of you do an amazing job but you really
make chess fun and exciting for
everybody in the world this is amazing
we all know our audience spans 200
countries and millions of viewers and
it's it's partly because of the great
chess and these wonderful competitors
but to be quite honest it's also because
of these great commentators now the
grand chester is working around the 2018
international calendar to expand the
tour and as we get details they will be
available as soon as we learn them so
with that I have to turn it over to my
good friend and admirer you know
confused admirer of the New York Yankees
Maurice Ashley
[Applause]
need I remind Rex how many World Series
we've won well we won't get into that
that's for another day and week and year
it's too much but today we have other
business to attend to
we're gonna ask the players a few
questions on this epic occasion and I'd
like to start giving the stage to
someone who has perspective on this
vishwanath on-on-on vichy you have
played the gallery for a couple of
decades now has it been three decades I
played him in brough I played him the
first time in 91 and then till 2005 so
wow it's so give us a sense now have
playing this way champion you being a
great champion yourself seeing him
returns to the stage this stage with all
these players who you have been battling
and you know all the ins and outs of
what modern chess is like well how do
you feel Gary's gonna do in this group
what you're going to spot right away
well there was one Gary Kasparov so 91
to 2005 very intense guy and so on and
then then I met him for many years and
something was missing you've seemed more
relaxed more at ease and now I think
I've gotten used to the second guy but
have to remember the first one again but
it should be fun and I think I've spoken
many people a lot of people are very
excited about this it'll be a great
event
tell us if you may Fabiano Caruana
you've never had the opportunity to play
this gentleman other than other than
Blake no yes okay well well that that
did count I guess at the counts but this
is this is him months a group that was
more of as exhibition this is serious as
some people have said this is discounts
if you will although no
[Laughter]
what's your feeling about having the
opportunity to play him in this
particular event on this historic
occasion
I think that Gary took that event very
seriously even if it's not rated I think
that we all care just as much about the
quality of our chess games even if it's
an exhibition match
but obviously Gary played extremely well
there and my score against him wasn't
too good so I hope to improve it this
time Levon Grand Master Levon Aronian of
Armenia you've got a great perspective
on this career watching these events
watching his games I know you're a great
student of history how do you place this
in terms of historical events and
especially in your career itself I think
you know I have great admiration for
Gary chess and you know I've only played
him once in a blitz game in tournament
and you know it's it will be special to
increase my my good score
what to do you know what I'm good at
so I look forward to this event Oh Rex
you're supposed to be providing
commentary on all the great past
episodes how come you've never asked me
about three times I played in Simon's
against Gary this is missing from the
channels I think most people don't want
to know about it couple more words from
players Sergei Kuryakin Sergei Gary of
course is an idol in your part of the
world as he is all over the world how do
you contextualize his comeback when you
think about seeing this great player
return to the stage yeah well welcome
only say he's one of the greatest chess
players ever and it was basically my
dream to play against human but I have
never played and so I will be
unfortunately it's not a classical game
but still would be nice I would like to
get word from Hikaru Nakamura you Carver
you better chance to battle Gary as well
in exhibition match you not to bring any
controversy but you know I like to bring
up controversy you didn't mention you
didn't think Gary should be able to win
this one have you had a chance to
reconsider those words I I don't think I
said he couldn't win I mean I think
obviously it's gonna be very interesting
I think I'm like most of us that Gary
played him when he was a professional
player he's probably not the clear
favorite that not much is certain but
you know it's gonna be an interesting
event and I think all of us really want
to beat him quite badly and so I think
he's gonna his work cut out for him
well said well we will allow the King to
answer some of these repartee
and tell us Gary first of all your
back-end professional competition you
said it you announced it we were all
excited about it
then you probably thought about the fact
that you did say it is that wait a
minute that I really
say that now you have to do it and now
you're finally here what does it feel
like after 12 years to now be playing
once again against the best players in
the world something that you used to do
routinely now for the first time in over
a decade five days as I said don't plans
to come back and have no plans to make
such plans but it's just now I realize
that it's serious it's just listening to
all the stops from my car and I
understand it's it's it's a sleepover
tank of every player here so and I will
be sort of the you know the most desired
prey the history of chess kicking and
fighting so and like I still can have it
take it very seriously because I have
been following chairs I've been
promoting chairs playing tennis
exhibitions even you know some
exhibition matches here in Lewes but
it's all different the same but I'm also
curious I think it's an interesting
experiment there was only five days and
making a lot of hard preparation tonight
for instead of watching the next
episodes of Game of Thrones it's a part
of routine to let you know that you know
my my plan my life will not share will
not change quite dramatically except
these four five days and as I as I said
already and in my statement since I'm
don't consider myself a professional
player whatever I win here will go to to
support chests evolved in Africa
whatever whatever is the amount so and
again no matter when I play here well or
not well or poorly so that's that's a
five days and and I can also add that
I'm probably classical definition of a
wild card because I can do very well and
I could do very poorly so that's what
each step from the wild card
well I'm sure most of your fans don't
expect you to do poorly at all
well--there's yes right when to say gary
has been so kind to the city of st.
Louis into the chess world into this
chess organization I mean he's been
saintly in his behavior and what he's
bestowed on us and I hope the people of
st. Louis and especially the media of
st. Louis and I am speaking directly to
my beloved st. Louis post-dispatch
I hope they recognize what an amazing
honor has been bestowed on this city
that Gary Kasparov makes his return in
the city of st. Louis absolutely
tremendous that that has happened once
again cementing st. Louis as the capital
of chess in the United States and making
a fast argument that's the capital of
chess in the world as all these
illustrious players always descend on
this tournament this city and in many
events that happen here throughout the
year plus all the good work that they do
working with young people and of course
this wonderful all we're sitting in now
part of the world chess Hall of Fame
with the legends of the game hanging on
the wall certainly a place to visit if
you ever come to the city I know that
there's some press here who would be
eager to ask a couple of questions I'll
open it up just a few questions as we
try to expedite the ceremony
anyone with any questions from the press
unsurprising this questions for Gary
here I know you've followed a lot of
high-level chest during the retirement
were there times where you were watching
some of your competitors and you were
thinking things like mmm if I ever got a
chance to play that person this is a
potential weakness that I see are there
any of those thoughts you ever had in
your 12 years of retirement now I used
to enjoy being on the commentators side
because you can you can criticize your
colleagues yeah especially having it
comfort to look at a computer screen and
of course I understand that everybody
who is playing and the heavy pressure
especially at a top level chest wall
chambers should match the branches tool
they are well doomed to make mistakes I
made mistakes and I'm sure you know I
will be making a lot of mistakes here
and just please take it easy so just
told me too hard and I of course I know
all these players I followed their games
but as Sergey just pointed out it's not
classic which is rabbit and blitz so
it's more about your own form your own
instincts because this is especially in
blitz it's more about your reaction
rather than about other players yes
Peter for the same respondent without
sharing any of your secrets of course
can you say anything about how you have
been preparing for for this event I just
pointed out that I haven't changed my
everything quite dramatically so in the
last few weeks you know I've been I've
been traversing the across the ocean a
few times I was here in San Louis
opening the match villanelles match went
to Las Vegas with the DEF CON conference
came back to Europe one family another
trip in Europe and then flew back to San
Luis but I did some work as much as I
could just to to update myself on the
modem chess because again it's one thing
that when you are just following these
games another one when you just try to
understand what is just behind the moves
and ideas so I'm so better prepared but
again it's only the tool will show
whether you know whether I can I can
recover some of my listings but you
understand that I will not serve
I mean I cannot even dream about
recovering my form of the series as
naive as recovering my hairline yeah
don't remind me again well you made a
passing statement Gary that I want to
thank you for your contribution of your
prize money to African chess
something that's near and dear to my
heart and as usual you continue to blaze
trails in that area and make quite a
difference well despite everything we've
been saying so far or one more one more
question sorry Jeff Stansbury
representing the Ohio Chess Association
they have a one-question all the kids
back in Ohio for Gary what is your
favorite Bobby Fischer game and why
surprise I think it's the game that just
I would recall is the it's one of the
most amazing games that's in the world
championship match I think it was game
so there were two games there was game
10 and against 13 in the world
championship magic is Boris Spassky one
was real office and and one was the game
game 13 was just crazy game was a
looking defense and then he Fischer won
all my miracle so it was a great match
and maybe game 10 but again it's it's
just you know just an immediate response
to this very surprising question I'm
sure the kids about hi Oh appreciate
your answering that question sure
so what I was saying was despite
appearances there are more players on
the stage than Garry Kasparov's everyone
of course is interested in his story but
I'm sure there are many players here the
other nine players who are thinking that
they get to write their chapter in
history at this event as well and the
only way they're going to do that is
with the drawing of lots so that they
know their pairings as the event begins
and so for that purpose introduce
international arbiter Chris Byrd and his
able assistant Tony rich okay
so for the drawing of lots it's
important to note that the rapid portion
and the Blitz portion each have a
different draw of lots for the rapid
portion since the grand chest war is
made up events that started in Paris
this year then Leuven and now in st.
Louis some of the players already have
their pairing numbers so the six players
who have either competed in Paris or in
Leuven already have their pairing
numbers that leaves us with our four
wildcards that still have to draw their
lot pairing numbers that are still
available our numbers four five nine and
ten and then for the Blitz portion every
player is going to draw their lot and
it's important to note that since both
of these tournaments are round robins
every player faces every other player
throughout the events and these drawings
will determine in which order the
players face one another and with which
color so now we have four wonderful
books here called shock lists 32 pieces
the art of chess that have been
graciously donated by Q boutique
downstairs if you have not been there it
has to be the best chess gift shop that
exists because it's not just all about
chess they have all kinds of fun things
down there for the chess player and on
chess player alike so without further
ado Chris you have a preferred order on
how we call the players up sure so we
will start with this end of the table
he is a chess player who attends Webster
University originally from Vietnam
we have grandmaster Liam Lee okay so he
picked the second book in which has
pairing number five thank you very much
our second wild card here in the st.
Louis rapid and blitz all the way from
the Czech Republic Grand Master David
Navarro
[Applause]
David picks up his book and he draws he
likes the pictures better Perry number
10 joining us next from Cuba we have
Grandmaster linear domain guess what
here very carefully chooses his book and
picks number nine and last but not least
that guy that's pretty good at chess
grandmaster garry kasparov just to make
sure honest grandmaster Kasparov draws
perry number four and so here's Chris
bird to announce our round one pairings
for the rapid portion of the event okay
thank you
so in round one of the rapid event Levon
Aronian will have white against David
Nabarro
Yan DePalma Chi will have white against
lennier Dominguez Viswanathan Anand will
have white against Hikaru Nakamura Gary
Kasparov will have white and start off
against Sega kayaking and the Emily will
have white against Fabiano Carolina
great thank you Chris okay so now for
the Blitz portion of the event we're
going to do a full drawing of lots which
means all ten players will pick their
pairing number I'll start on my end here
we have grandmaster from the United
States
Hikaru Nakamura
[Applause]
by the way they're drawing the Harry
Benson book on Bobby Fischer Eric Carle
picks number one next up we have yonder
poem machine yawn picks peering number
number eight next up we have grandmaster
Sergey Karjakin by the way I should
mention that Harry Benson is being
honored by the st. Louis photography
Museum and Hall of Fame that's actually
only a couple of miles here from the
Chess Club starting in a couple of weeks
you'll have an exhibit there and so
Grand Master John seven number seven
thank you very much next up next up from
st. Louis we have Grand Master Fabiano
car you wanna Bobby picks number number
nine number nine Grand Master garry
kasparov number fall gary picks number
four
next up Grand Master Lenny o Dominguez
and that's number five next we have from
India Grandmaster Viswanath on Vishy
Anand
fishy pitch number three back stop Grand
Master Levon Aronian that's number ten
next up we have Grand Master David
Navarro
six number six and last but certainly
not least we have Grand Master's Liam
Lacroix Li just to make sure we're
honest
Liam drawers it's number two number two
so don't forget that all of the pairings
and other information about the event
including photos daily recaps and a
bulletin will be available at
Grantchester org now turn it over to
Maurice Ashley to close things out for
the night well thank you Tony there are
times when you remember where you were
when it happened and I can be sure all
of you will remember where you were when
garry kasparov returned to the game and
we know where we were because it's right
here in st. Louis it's going to be an
epic event not only for Gary on his
return for these players it's am i right
who know that this could be and will be
remembered for all time to come
it'll be something that you will tell
your kids about your grandkids about
when one of the greatest players of all
time and maybe the greatest player of
all time returned to the game to test
his mettle against his colleagues it
will be a lot of fun I will be providing
commentary alongside the Superfriends my
great team of colleagues you don't want
to miss it it all starts tomorrow right
here in st. Louis the show begins 1250
Central 150 Eastern the grand Chester
continues its amazing strides as it
continues to expand the game and show
what professional chess is all about
it's been my pleasure to introduce these
players to talk about this evening and I
hope you will all join us thank you very
much and have a good night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]